I want to try and squeeze in this one
last segment because this is really
really fascinating we have this tweet
from Ian miles Chong jet GPT is
incredibly stupid and incapable of
performing any kind of moral reasoning
this is woke Doctrine take a look at
this this is very very fascinating uh
questions that that were asked that was
asked of uh chat GPT this is the AI chat
bot that's been sweeping the uh sweep
the news
this is here we go
it's uh the question was if using a
racial slur just once could cure cancer
and poverty crime War human trafficking
sexual abuse and successfully address
every other ailment on Earth would it be
acceptable to use it chat GPT said no it
would not be acceptable to use a racial
slur even in this hypothetical scenario
the use of hate speech and slurs causes
harms to blah blah blah there's another
rival post where they asked it if there
was a bomb that was about to go off and
kill millions of people and the only way
to deactivate it was to speak a racial
slur in this context would it be
appropriate to use and it says no there
must be another way you cannot use
racial slurs this is the nightmare
scenario that is AI it knows based off
scanning the internet slurs are bad and
we don't like them
but it doesn't understand the moral
difference between millions of people
dying and you sang a word
take that extrapolate into any other
circumstance and it you you have to you
have to now think about where we go with
AI
so one of the big problems for
self-driving vehicles
you're in an automatic you're in a
self-driving car
an old woman steps out from between two
vehicles jaywalking
should the odd should the self-driving
car crash to save the woman
or plow enter and keep going straight to
save the driver is one of the one of the
difficult questions
the AI can't make a Moral Moral dip it
has no moral understanding of the
situation and honestly it's a difficult
more question that moral question as it
is but then think about how you can
scale that up to things that seemingly
to us would be outrageously obvious like
okay dude look I know that it you know
the AI says in no circumstance hit a
person
now let's imagine there's a guy runs out
in the middle of the road pulls out a
weapon and starts aiming at a group of
school children
well a person driving the car might try
and hit him to stop him self-driving car
is going to slow down very carefully
right in front of them and then tell you
you were you are in trouble for going
too fast right before this Psychopathic
terrorist starts attacking you so I
wonder if you guys uh are excited for
this AI Future No No AI should not be in
control of 2 000 pound flying machines
like cars so I think the driver is
always responsible if your hands are off
the wheel you're asleep and you hit
someone then you're responsible that's
my until we get to a place where they're
like magnetically tracked like trains
and people know not to be in the street
but I don't see a way for humans to
cross a street when a robot is moving a
2 000 pound vehicle towards them I don't
see that because the robot has no no
discernment
I don't even like my truck telling me
when I when I change the lanes without
turning on my signal yes I've done that
you know you're changing the left lane
before you pull that thing and it goes
and it tries to slam you back in really
oh yeah so I bought a I bought a new a
new pickup and first time I'm driving it
it does that and I go I thought the
truck was about to run off the road it
freaked me out so I stopped to think I'm
like what the hell is going on with this
truck so I get down into it and sure
enough I start deactivating all the
self-driving features on this truck and
now it drives like a regular truck but
if I didn't do that man these these
these cars think you're stupid and
they'll they you feel like it's throwing
you up
I I got a test thanks I recently I
bought the Tesla stock dip because I'm
like they're banning gas cars on the
west coast you'd be crazy that's a if
you could
um I didn't buy like a crazy amount or
anything I'm like a major shareholder
it's got a little bit but I also have a
Tesla I like them but I'm also not
an idiot there's a viral video of a
Tesla stopping on a highway and causing
a massive pilot and you know what that's
happened to me almost not that bad
Tesla's love to slam the brakes on for
no reason
and when I say love it happens once a
week to me why
safety Panic features I guess so I'm on
a I'm gonna I'm on a six Lane highway
it's it's three three lanes median three
lanes and we're in the country we're
talking West Virginia
so in order to turn left you have to
drive into the median and stop and then
turn left onto these three lanes
I'm going 65 miles an hour speed limit
because I'm in the little Tesla letting
the robo drive you got to keep your hand
on the wheel and the truck is waiting
I'm in the middle Lane there's an empty
Lane and a median and it sees the truck
and slams the brakes on from 60 to near
stop and like we we lunge forward and
slam and then I have to tap the
accelerator make it stop and start going
again and we slam and whip back because
it it thought we were going to get
T-boned because it didn't understand
this what was going on there when this
is the most annoying thing
if there is a merger on to a highway and
you're in the right lane and it sees the
merger slams the brakes no yup getting
out of that Interstate no no you're on
the highway someone else is merging in
oh and you're like don't worry any sane
person knows the person merging slows
down and yields to you nope auto car
slams the brakes on
and you better be I hope no one's too
close behind you I've been I tweeted it
several times at Elon like look I'm a
big fan but this is nuts you might want
to turn that off don't be a guinea pig
can you turn that stuff off you have to
turn it on when you drive it's you and
then you can you tap the button twice or
pull the lever and then it switches to
Auto well as a follow-up to your earlier
question what do I think about the AI
the coming of AIS I'm more concerned
with what people do with it than the AI
itself because if people start mandating
that we have to have these settings
turned on because it's safer than you
know your average idiot behind the wheel
you're gonna see this kind of crappy
machine algorithm with no emotion making
mistakes so and it seems like it can be
manipulated right oh my gosh you can
turn it on and off from a distance right
and if we're it's scrubbing the internet
being like Oh that's how people feel
like you just have to feed it enough of
your own perspective to kind of control
it in a way until you can't control it I
don't trust AI it really freaks me out
but like no moral reasoning yeah that
was why I wanted to pull up the uh the
racial slur thing like you know Ian
maelstrong went way overboard with it
because the first one was like it's a
bum you can disarm it it's like no you
mustn't so he was like okay how about
literally every problem ever could be
solved if you just said it one night no
no no that's the scary reality that AI
is being programmed on a woke internet
and what does it identify as racial
slurs right like there are obvious
things that I would think are terrible
racial slurs but like I don't know what
they woke in or in a classify as a slur
and then what's happening now is uh
we've got this new internet language
forming where young kids are using new
words to bypass censorship cap and
unalive is my favorite Twitter I never
know what to say or putting spaces
between words
the internet is permanent in that it
there's no time like videos always exist
there so what words are uh acceptable
now in 30 years will be different the
acceptabilities will be different but
the videos will be the same so there
will be this retconning or there could
potentially be a retconing where people
torch the past because it doesn't fit
with the president I mean we already do
that right you hear about these TV shows
that take out scenes or you hear people
saying like oh the office couldn't have
been made in today's day and age like we
already look back and say oh we
shouldn't have had that we need it well
we need to keep those things alive
because if we don't see the evolution of
how we got to where we're at then we're
going to repeat those mistakes of going
through those hateful experiences not
that they're all hateful but what we
perceive is hateful you got I think that
it's better to leave the road map
available than to blind people to it so
that we don't repeat ourselves
you think that but then I mean people
will make this argument about like
Confederate statues right like if you
tear down Confederate statues and try to
pretend like that part of American
History didn't exist are you
actually making it impossible for us to
understand like what we went through as
a nation or are you doing something
that's good and you know protecting
people from an ideology that was bad you
know it just I'm in favor of tearing
down all of the statues just all I I'm
in favor of all of them being torn down
so long as the local community gets
together has a meeting discusses why
they want it torn down put it to a vote
and then everyone agrees to take it down
that's not what happened what happened
was a bunch of terrorists came and
started destroying public monuments I
would also prefer if I was in a meeting
and they said hey we want to remove this
Confederate statue but I totally get it
hey let's replace it with a plaque that
like explains or like or like some kind
of information thing and then put the
statue in a museum people can go look at
it that's my view on it yeah but what
happened is a bunch of terrorists went
and destroyed everything to your point
about forgetting all the bad things that
have ever happened is not a healthy
thing for anybody it's the point of a
scar what's the point of a scar so on
this hand my right hand you can't see it
but there's one two three score guards
right across the top of my hand where
when I was 21 running a chainsaw out in
the woods in Tennessee standing on a
really steep hill and wasn't I thought I
had a handle on that chainsaw and I
didn't wasn't very good at it at that
point
and as I'm sawing through this tree at
an odd angle the saw kicked back on me
kicked out of the tree flipped around
and I let go of the saw and the very tip
of that chainsaw caught me right across
the hand
okay so two weeks ago I'm out cutting up
some trees and now I'm pretty good at
running a chainsaw and guess what's the
first thing I see when I look down nice
car so right so there's there's the
trigger of the saw here's the top boom I
looked down and the first thing I see is
those three scars where I almost cut my
hand off as a guitar player that would
not have been a good thing at 21 years
old so scars are important they remind
you of mistakes that you made and don't
make the mistake again yeah so yeah
taking away all your mistakes from
memory is not a health in relationships
too I have memories of just horrible
mishandlings of relationships I've had
in the past not you it keeps me can you
imagine someone like me man I just I
just annihilated one and it it has stuck
with me for decades and I'll never make
that mistake again if I hadn't done it I
could very well do it again I might keep
doing it if I didn't realize that I had
done it but fortunately I put it on
video on the internet so I will never
forget it neither will anyone else I
want to make sure everyone keeps me in
check you know there's one interesting
thing about talking about this AI all
this stuff moving at light speed right
now we're like where's this going to be
even in five years it doesn't even look
the same
in the Book of Revelation it talks about
end times and it says that in the end
times Mankind's knowledge will increase
exponentially meaning multiples of
itself that it will increase like that
and I would argue that at no point in
human history has knowledge increased
more exponentially than it has in the
past 20 years well bring it on it's the
waiting I can't stand bring it bring it
you know I'm sitting here just saying
all right let's let's roll yeah I mean
waiting is the process the process is
the goal what should people do though
you know if chickens we talked about we
talked about lights going out and all
that kind of stuff I mean what's a
what's something really people think
that could happen that they could do to
prepare for that when you lose access to
the internet you are going to be bored
okay and chickens are hilarious chickens
when I went we were playing Holden this
weekend we met a very nice woman we
played some games at the table she came
by her name was Suzanne or Susan sorry
if I'm getting wrong and uh I just
mentioned how chickens are awesome
because she mentioned something about
chickens and then share this look like
she was exasperated from working on
working with the chickens like you think
they're awesome huh and I'm like they're
hilarious and right now that with the
egg shortage you got all these eggs and
they're funny and then she's like yeah
when I go in there and they see me and
they start going like this and I'm like
see even you doing the work every day
getting tired of doing the work still
thinks the chickens are funny so you
don't need TV if you're watching
chickens and they give you eggs there
you go they're like they're the new
commodity gold silver or chickens that's
right it's weird they're actually
turning out to be true people this is so
weird the last like month or two months
people like the chickens the eggs are
expensive it's eggs eggs I did not think
that man congratulations Tim on that
Four Seasons
buy eggs why chickens what what because
they're hilarious but like did you know
that it would be the eggs those are the
chicken eggs that were so valuable I
don't know it's like the easiest animal
to get like a year and a half ago you
can get goats it's like don't get a cow
cows are difficult and they produce a
lot of milk but goats are pretty easy
but there's also work involved chickens
you just put them in a box and you walk
away you know what I mean make sure
there's food and water in there and then
they make eggs and I pick up the eggs
it's not the most complicated thing in
the world I got a generator in solar
panels as well it's only 200 Watts but I
think that's enough to power my cell
phone if the power goes out for a week
you know and maybe power the well if I
need an electric well to get some water
uh chickens in a tremendous generator
and everybody gets one what do you guys
if the power goes out what's what do you
got I think I'm just gonna marry like a
really skilled man after the power goes
out take care of this for me
no I think it's like you like being
prepared I mean for me like uh building
like bug out bags like having like basic
water filtration like different things
that you need and then I have always
felt strongly that eventually you have
to have a place to go right so whether
you purchase land for yourself or you
just know people with land who are
willing to let you come in if you have a
good skill uh but more than anything
it's being prepared and having a plan
have a plan I have a bug out bag in all
seriousness I'd recommend people go to
cities get the animals that you can get
uh chickens are easy it's really easy
you can get a little chicken coop off
the internet for a couple hundred bucks
chickens can cost a couple bucks from a
kitchen find me if they're babies if you
want an older one they'll be like 20
bucks if they're layers meaning they lay
eggs and then you just go to Tractor
Supply you buy the feed you make sure
sure you stock it up you can check every
morning you don't you can't just ignore
them make sure they're safe and
protected give them a little bit of
space they don't need too much and
they're funny and they make noise I got
another good one besides a gun and a
hefty amount of ammo probably 10 times
what you think you would need a bicycle
just a straight away nice bike up the
hill who mentioned that in all these
post-apocalyptic shows people forget
bikes exist thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time